BETTER BY THE DAY.
BILL MELUGIN BACK IN EAGLE PASS
TODAY.
>> Dana: LAWMAKERS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE SAY THE END
OF TITLE 42 COULD PRODUCE
CATASTROPHIC RESULTS INCLUDING
TEXAS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR DAN
PATRICK WHO JOINS ME NOW.
SOMETHING FROM THE MAYORKAS,
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CABINET
SECRETARIES.
IF CDC RESCINDED ITS TITLE 42
ORDER AT THE TIME LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE FORCED THE
AB SOARED THE CURRENT NUMBER OF
MIGRANTS WITH CATASTROPHIC
RESULTS.
THAT'S A LETTER THEY HAD OUT
THERE.
I'M ASSUMING THAT YOU ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS ESPECIALLY
FOR YOUR AGENTS.
>> EXACTLY, DANA.
AND OUR AGENTS PUT THEIR LIVES
ON THE LINE EVERY DAY.
IS THIS THE WAY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WANTS PEOPLE TO
COME TO AMERICA ZIPPED UP IN A
DUFFEL BAG WITH A CAR ON FIRE?
HE DOESN'T GIVE A DAMN ABOUT
THE LIVES OF PEOPLE CROSSING
THE BORDER OR AMERICANS.
HE HAS WALKED BACK AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION WALKED BACK JUST
ABOUT EVERYTHING HE SAYS.
WILL HE WALK BACK THIS POLICY
ON ENDING TITLE 42?
I DOUBT IT.
YOU KNOW, IN THE OLD DAYS ELVIS
USED TO SAY TCB.
TAKING CARE OF BUSINESS.
BIDEN'S VERSION OF THAT IS GCV.
GREEN CARD, CITIZENSHIP AND
VOTING.
HERE ARE THE NUMBERS.
BASED ON THE 2 MILLION PLUS WE
APPREHENDED LAST YEAR ON THE
BORDER AND THE 2.5 MILLION WE
MAY GET MORE THIS YEAR OVER THE
BIDEN FIRST FOUR YEARS WE WILL
APPREHEND 10 MILLION PEOPLE
CROSSING THE BORDER.
WE THINK WE GET 1 OUT OF EVERY
3.
ANOTHER 20 MILLION.
THAT'S 30 MILLION PEOPLE.
THAT'S FOUR NEW YORK CITIES.
FOUR NEW YORK CITIES COMING
INTO THIS COUNTRY.
HE WANTS TO GIVE THEM GREEN
CARDS BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO WORK.
THEN HE WANTS TO GIVE THEM
CITIZENSHIP BECAUSE THAT'S NEXT
SO THEY VOTE AND KEEP DEMOCRATS
IN POWER.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
GREEN CARD, CITIZENSHIP,
VOTING, 10 MILLION PEOPLE TO
STAY IN POWER AND TAKE OVER
THIS COUNTRY.
>> Dana: LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THE DRUG
SEIZURES AS WELL.
METH, IF YOU JUST LOOK AT THIS
IN 2020 WAS 172,000 POUNDS AND
IN 2021, 182,000 POUNDS.
WE KNOW THIS IS GOING UP ACROSS
THE BOARD FOR FENTANYL, COCAINE
AS WELL.
OVERDOSE DEATHS IN TEXAS IF YOU
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS QUICKLY.
I KNOW YOU KNOW THEM BUT FOR
THE VIEWERS, IT HAS GONE UP
DRAMATICALLY.
THAT'S A LOT OF HEARTACHE.
>> HEARTACHE, A LOT OF DEATH, A
LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY WHO ARE DYING LONG
BEFORE THEY SHOULD.
IT IS BECOMING ONE OF THE TOP
KILLERS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AGAIN, THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
-- I CAN'T SAY THIS MORE
CLEARLY.
HE DOESN'T CARE.
HE CANNOT BE THIS NAIVE.
YOU TALKED EARLIER IN THE DAY
THAT PUTIN SEES WHAT IS GOING
ON AROUND THE WORLD AND THAT HE
IS NOT PROTECTED.
BIDEN MUST WATCH TELEVISION
SOMETIMES AND SEE THE STORIES
AND READ SOMETHING OR IS HIS
ADMINISTRATION KEEPING HIM IN
THE DARK AS THEY ALLEGE THE
PUTIN ADMINISTRATION IS KEEPING
HIM IN THE DARK?
I SERIOUSLY DOUBT IT.
BIDEN KNOWS WHAT'S GOING ON.
I CANNOT SAY THIS ANY STRONGER.
HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THE LIVES
OF PEOPLE.
HE ONLY CARES ABOUT ACHIEVING A
POLITICAL VICTORY AND THAT'S
GIVING 10 MILLION, 20 MILLION,
30 MILLION PEOPLE CITIZENSHIP
IN THE FIRST FOUR YEARS IN
OFFICE.
IT MAY TAKE SEVERAL YEARS.
SOME OF THOSE ARE UNDER 18 SO
THAT THEY CAN ADD 30 MILLION
VOTERS TO THE ROLLS.
FOUR NEW YORK CITIES WILL COME
INTO THIS COUNTRY IN HIS FIRST
FOUR YEARS IN OFFICE.
IN TEXAS WE'RE OVERRUN.
THEY ARE COMING TO A CITY AND
TOWN NEAR YOU.
EVERY SHERIFF IN EVERY COUNTY
IN AMERICA IS A BORDER COUNTY
SHERIFF AND THEY'RE COMING
EVERYWHERE.
WE NORMALLY SPEND A HALF
BILLION A YEAR ON BORDER
SECURITY.
THIS YEAR I'VE AUTHORIZED ALONG
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE NEARLY 3 1/2
BILLION AND IT IS GOING UP JUST
TO DO OUR JOB THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD.